lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
introducir la idea de cómo surge el
carbono 14 y cómo llega a todos los
seres vivos y luego tanto en este vídeo
como en los vídeos futuros hablaremos de
cómo se usa realmente para adaptar cosas
como lo utilizamos para descifrar que
este hueso tiene 12.000 años de edad o
que esa persona murió 18 mil años atrás
cualquiera que sea el caso
déjame dibujar la tierra déjame solo
dibujar la superficie de la tierra de
esta manera
es sólo una pequeña sección de la
superficie de la tierra y luego tenemos
a la atmósfera de la tierra la dibujaré
en amarillo luego tienes la atmósfera de
la tierra justo así
déjame escribir eso atmósfera
y el 78% el elemento más abundante en
nuestra atmósfera es el nitrógeno el 78%
es nitrógeno y escribiré nitrógeno su
símbolo es simplemente n y tiene 7
protones y también tiene 7 neutrones
tiene una masa atómica de 14
aproximadamente
este es el isótopo más común del
nitrógeno y hablamos de la palabra
isótopo en la serie de vídeos de química
los protones definirán qué elemento es
pero este número aquí arriba puede
cambiar dependiendo del número de
neutrones que tengas así que las
diferentes versiones de un elemento dado
son llamadas isótopos simplemente los
imagino como versiones de un elemento
de todas maneras tenemos nuestra
atmósfera y luego viniendo de nuestro
sol y de otras fuentes fuera de nuestro
sistema solar tenemos los que comúnmente
son llamados rayos cósmicos pero de
hecho no son rayos son partículas
cósmicas puedes pensarlas simplemente
como protones individuales es lo mismo
que decir núcleos de hidrógeno también
pueden ser partículas alfa lo cual es lo
mismo que núcleos de helio e incluso hay
unos cuantos electrones
y van a entrar y van a encontrarse con
elementos en nuestra atmósfera y de
hecho van a formar neutrones realmente
van a formar neutrones
y mostraremos a un neutrón con la n
minúscula y 11 para su número mágico y
no escribimos algo aquí porque no tienes
protones aquí arriba como en el caso del
nitrógeno con 7 protones así que
realmente no es un elemento es una
partícula subatómica pero tienes esta
formación de neutrones y de vez en
cuando y simplemente seamos claros esta
no es una reacción típica pero de vez en
cuando uno de esos neutrones
chocará con
nitrógeno
justo de la manera correcta para que se
desprenda uno de los protones en el
nitrógeno y esté esencialmente reemplace
a este protón con el mismo déjame
aclarar esto se desprende uno de los
protones así que en lugar de siete
protones ahora tenemos seis protones
pero este número 14 no baja a 13 porque
el mismo lo reemplaza así que la masa
atómica se queda en 14
y ahora ya que solo tiene 6 protones
este ya no es un hidrógeno por
definición ahora es carbono y ese protón
que fue desechado simplemente se
desprende así que ahora déjame hacerlo
en otro color tenemos más y un protón
que está simplemente volando alrededor
lo puede llamar hidrógeno 1 y puede
ganar un electrón de alguna manera si no
gana un electrón es solo un ión de
hidrógeno unión positivo de cualquier
manera o un núcleo de hidrógeno pero
este proceso y repito no es un proceso
típico pero sucede de vez en cuando así
es como se forma el carbono 14
y este de aquí es carbono 14
puedes verlo esencialmente como un
nitrógeno 14 donde uno de los protones
es reemplazado con un neutrón y lo que
es interesante de esto es que se forma
constantemente en nuestra atmósfera no
en grandes cantidades pero en cantidades
razonables así que déjame escribir esto
se forma constantemente
formación
constante
y lo que pasa es y déjame ser muy clara
veamos la tabla periódica de aquí arriba
el carbono típico el carbono por
definición tiene 6 protones pero el
isótopo típico el isótopo más común del
carbono es el carbono 12 el carbono 12
es el
más
así que la mayor parte del carbono en tu
cuerpo es carbono 12 pero lo que es
interesante es que una pequeña fracción
de carbono 14 se forma y luego este
carbono 14 se puede combinar con oxígeno
para formar dióxido de carbono y luego
ese dióxido de carbono es absorbido por
el resto de la atmósfera por los océanos
puede ser fijado por las plantas cuando
la gente habla de la fijación del
carbono realmente se refiere a usar
principalmente energía luminosa del sol
para tomar el carbono gaseoso y
transformarlo en realidad en un tipo de
tejido orgánico y entonces este carbono
14 se forma constantemente llega a los
océanos
ya está en el aire pero se mezcla
completamente a través de toda la
atmósfera los océanos
el aire
y luego se dirige a las
plantas
y las plantas en realidad están
constituidas por ese carbono fijado ese
carbono que fue tomado en una forma
gaseosa y transformado en creo que
podrías decir en algo parecido a un
estado sólido transformado en una forma
viviente eso es lo que la madera es más
o menos se introduce en las plantas y
luego se introducen en los seres que las
comen y ellos podrían ser esos podríamos
ser nosotros
y por qué es esto interesante acabo de
explicar un mecanismo donde una parte de
tu cuerpo a pesar de que el carbono 12
es el isótopo más común una parte de
nuestro cuerpo mientras estamos viviendo
se forma de este carbono 14 bueno lo
interesante es que el único momento
donde puedes tomar este carbono 14 es
mientras estás vivo mientras comes
nuevos alimentos porque en el momento en
el que mueres y eres enterrado bajo
tierra no hay forma en la que el carbono
aún se vuelva parte de tu tejido porque
no estás comiendo nada que tenga carbono
14 nuevo y lo que es interesante aquí es
que una vez que mueres no obtendrás más
carbono 14 nuevo y ese carbono 14 que ya
tenías al momento de tu muerte decae
-mediante desintegración beta y ya
aprendimos eso nuevamente
nitrógeno 14 algo parecido a este
proceso pero al revés va a descomponerse
de nuevo en nitrógeno 14
y va a decaer mediante desintegración
beta desprende un electrón
y un anti neutrino no entraré en
detalles de eso pero esencialmente lo
que sucede aquí es que uno de los
neutrones se convierte en un protón y
desprende estos productos en el proceso
ahora por qué es esto interesante acabo
de decir que mientras vives tienes un
tipo de carbono 14 y el carbono 14 hace
constantemente está descomposición pero
lo que es interesante es que tan pronto
como mueres y dejas de ingerir plantas o
dejar de respirar de la atmósfera si
eres una planta o fijando de la
atmósfera una vez que una planta muere
ya no toma dióxido de carbono de la
atmósfera y ya no lo transforma en
tejido nuevo el carbono 14 en ese tejido
se congela y este carbono 14 decae a una
tasa específica y luego puedes utilizar
esta tasa para determinar realmente hace
cuánto tiempo este tejido tuvo que haber
muerto la tasa en la que esto sucede
la tasa de decaimiento del carbono-14 es
esencialmente que la mitad
se va
aproximadamente cinco mil setecientos
treinta años
y a esto de hecho se le llama vida media
y hablamos de esto en otros vídeos
esto es llamado vida
media
y quiero ser clara aquí no sabes que en
mitad se fue es algo aleatorio no podés
solo decir que todo el carbono 14 en la
izquierda de caerá y todo el carbono 14
en la derecha no decaerá en esos cinco
mil setecientos treinta años lo que dice
esencialmente es que cualquier átomo de
carbono 14 tiene un 50% de probabilidad
de decaer en nitrógeno 14 en 5.700 30
años en el transcurso de 5.730 años
aproximadamente la mitad de ellos habrán
decaído
ahora porque es eso interesante bien si
sabes que todas las cosas vivas tienen
una cierta proporción de carbono 14 en
su tejido como parte de lo que las
conforman y si encontrarás un hueso
digamos que encontramos un hueso justo
aquí que desenterrase de una especie de
excavación arqueológica dices
este hueso tiene la mitad del carbono 14
que todas las cosas vivientes que ves
ahora sería una estimación bastante
razonable decir bien ese hueso deberá de
tener cinco mil setecientos treinta años
incluso mejor
quizá excavar us un poco más profundo y
encontrarás otro hueso
tal vez unos cuantos pies más abajo
y dices wow sabes que este hueso de aquí
tiene un cuarto del carbono-14 que
esperarías encontrar en un ser vivo que
tan viejo es esto bien si solo tiene un
cuarto del carbono-14 debió de haber
pasado por dos vidas medias después de
una vida media debió de haber tenido la
mitad del carbono y después de otra vida
media la mitad de este también se
convierte en nitrógeno 14 y entonces
esto implicaría dos vidas
a medias
qué es lo mismo que dos veces 5.730
años
o dirías que este hueso sería que este
hueso tiene once mil cuatrocientos
sesenta años más o menos